in my first are learning from legends
video I looked at the life and lessons
of Arnold Schwarzenegger I had planned
to cover Houdini next but there was a
huge number of requests to cover Bruce
Lee first and so here we are I've
discussed Bruce Lee a few times on this
channel and to be honest there's so much
content out there recounting his life in
biography that I'm not sure I have a lot
to contribute to that discussion
I recommend Bruce Lee fighting spirit
for those interested in a detailed
biography and apparently the recent
Bruce Lee a life is also a very good
read instead then I'm going to take a
look at some of the highlights and most
interesting points from Bruce Lee's life
using this information will then try and
deconstruct what made him the global
icon that he became not his philosophy
not his training nor his martial arts
but his decisions actions and demeanour
what can we learn from Bruce Lee the man
oh and if you want to be involved and
help to choose the next legend to be
covered in this series then you can head
over to the patreon page where I'll be
running a poll as I said the key points
in Bruce Lee's life are well documented
he was born in Chinatown San Francisco
on November 27th 1940 on the hour and
year of the dragon while his family was
touring the United States however he
moved back to Hong Kong shortly after
where he'll be raised by his parents
McCoy Chuen and he part European either
German or British grace hope they
actually began appearing in movies from
a very young age having been introduced
to the industry by his father one of the
leading cantonese opera and film actors
at the time in fact his very first film
appearance was at the age of three
months old when he was a stand-in for a
baby in the film Golden Gate Girl during
the family's short time in the u.s. in
Hong Kong he continued to appear in
around 20 different films as a child
actor from 1946 onwards during his
childhood he also enjoyed dance going on
to win a cha-cha competition and poetry
it's very interesting to note Bruce's
early interest at this point as they
foreshadow and help to explain some of
his subsequent accomplishments acting
from a young age in particular would
likely have helped Bruce's
confidence outgoing nature and charisma
acting classes or alternatively stand-up
comedy are fantastic tools for those
seeking to become more dynamic and
engaging or to overcome social anxiety
of course there's also a chance that his
cha-cha background helped to lay the
foundations for his physicality footwork
and rhythm dance actually has a lot in
common with martial arts requiring full
body control and wrote to memorization
of complex sequences of movements as a
poet we see that Bruce truly was an
artistic soul from a young age his
daughter Shannon speaking of his poetry
would later describe him as the
consummate artist
you boys done playing as he got older
bruce lee reportedly got into several
fights with local gangs though the
seriousness of these fights is debated
with some reports likely being
embellished nevertheless this motivated
Bruce to begin training in wing chun
kung fu' in 1957 making him around 17
under the tutelage of the famous Yip Man
reportedly Bruce's mixed heritage meant
that other students were reluctant to
train with him at the time it was
unpopular to train non-asians in martial
arts
this combined with Ali's obvious passion
for the subject led to rare one-to-one
training from yet man
Bruce was also coached in boxing his
primary school by brother Edwards and
would go on to win the school tournament
at various other undefined points in his
life Bruce Lee also had other forms of
martial arts training
Danny Inosanto reported that he had
already experienced Wu style Tai Chi
when he arrived in Hong Kong reportedly
also had fencing training from his
brother of particular note here was the
fact that Bruce Lee began his training
at age 17 and only trained consecutively
for two years before moving to the US
this hopefully just goes to show that
you don't have to start training as a
young child in order to become highly
adept in any physical regimen it's never
too late to be what you always wanted to
be also interesting is the wide range of
different fighting styles that Bruce Lee
trained in throughout his lifetime he
reportedly supplemented this training
with other styles including Troy Lee
foot to Singh II Jiu Jitsu and judo he
was constantly learning and gaining more
knowledge from different fields
they only makes sense then that Bruce
Lee's ideas would go on to inspire mixed
martial arts and it's also refreshing to
see just how Bruce Lee avoided the
temptation to become wed to a single
style or set of ideas too often we
become jealously protective over one
style or another as it becomes a part of
our identity and we begin to belong to a
niche this doesn't just refer to martial
arts all this accomplishes is to limit
our own ideas and great many would
dismiss the martial practicality of Tai
Chi for instance but it's much wiser to
realize you can learn something from
everything he would even go on to
incorporate bodybuilding and other forms
of physical training as I often discuss
on this channel as Bruce Lee was
well-known to say absorb what is useful
discard loss is useless and add what is
specifically your own subsequent to this
though it would be Bruce's own
dedication practice and passion that
would elevate him to the level of
physical excellence that he ultimately
achieved as he also famously said I fear
not the manners practiced 10,000 kicks
once but I fear the man who has
practiced one kick 10,000 times this was
Bruce's approach to everything and he
was superhuman Lee committed to his art
in 1959 the decision was made to send
Bruce to America to make a better life
and possibly to put an end to the
brawling at the University of Washington
Bruce Lee studied Dramatic Arts
psychology and philosophy among other
subjects contrary to popular belief
according to a university alumni
publication Bruce's official major was
drama not philosophy nevertheless Bruce
Lee was very passionate about the latter
and it is only now that he's recognized
for his many philosophical writings
check out some of the articles over at
brain pickings for some really
interesting leads he was also a prolific
reader himself with an extensive
personal library that informed many of
his own ideas and musings one of the
books that was the most influential for
Bruce was the tale teaching which also
went on to inspire many other schools of
thought including Buddhism Confucianism
legalism and others a central concept of
the tayo teaching and one that struck a
particular chord with Greece is that of
leeway or non action this is essentially
spontaneity and flow going with nature
and not overthinking not only with this
influence Bruce's personality we
was also very informed by the 60s but
also the development of his martial arts
which were all about reactive
instinctual movement and expressing
yourself honestly this is something that
truly set Bruce Lee apart as a man and
as an artist Bruce Lee used his personal
philosophy to inform everything from his
decisions in life to his movements in
that way you can argue he found a life
purpose he believed a hundred percent in
everything he did because it was all
borne out of his own interpretation of
the best way to live if you haven't
given thought to your own personal
philosophy this is something that is
very much worth doing around the same
time Bruce Lee would meet his future
wife Linda Lee Cadwell also a student at
the college who he married in August
1964 they went on to have two children
Brandon and Shannon Lee in 1965 and 1969
respectively also during this time Bruce
Lee founded his own martial arts school
Jin Fang gongfu which taught his own
interpretation of Wing Chun it was
through his martial arts that Bruce Lee
would meet many of his celebrity friends
but it was through the Long Beach
International karate championship where
he would ultimately make the biggest
splash it was here that he famously
demonstrated his one-inch punch and two
fingered push-ups this was 1964 at this
point had been training for seven years
in numerous styles not a long amount of
time by most standards and yet these
displays of pure physicality his
charisma his ability to package and sell
ideas like these and the speeds and
precision of his strikes were enough to
make him instantly unforgettable of
course Bruce Lee's showmanship also
wrestled some feathers in 1964 Bruce had
his infamous and controversial private
match against Wong Jack man at rx2 dn't
of mark in Fung Bruce Lee reports that
he was challenged to the match in order
to settle a dispute with the Chinese
community of whether he should be
teaching non Chinese people martial arts
as a victim of discrimination himself
and as someone I didn't believe in dogma
and arbitrary rules bruce lee was keen
to smash the cultural barriers and share
his art with the world the match was
witnessed by Linda James Lee and William
Chen reports here are very hazy though
and it's not entirely clear what
happened ultimately though Bruce Lee
would continue to teach whoever he chose
potentially inspired by this experience
Bruce Lee began to develop his fighting
style further through 90
67 giving birth to the now-famous Jeet
Kune Do
Jeet Kune Do translates to way of the
intercepting fist and teaches students
to dispel with the classical mess of
traditional martial arts to combine
styles and to ultimately focus on direct
strikes honest self-expression and
adapting to situations on the fly
Bruce further continues to develop
himself physically as well incorporating
more weight training methods endurance
training flexibility and more he had
this to say on the matter
training is one of the most neglected
phases of athletics too much time is
given to the development of skill and
too little to the development of the
individual for participation JKD
ultimately is not a matter of petty
technique but of highly developed
spirituality and physique again Lee is
breaking down traditions established
norms and attempting to find deeper core
truths he would later go on to say that
he regretted introducing the name Jeet
Kune Do even as it formalize his
approach into a style and approached the
core tenant of which was to do away with
formalized rules restrictions and styles
I'm reminded here for saying if you meet
the Buddha on the road kill him
in other words Bruce Lee did not see his
way as the one true way but rather felt
that there was no such thing this is
very clear once more then to see how his
fighting style was an expression of his
philosophy of course I'm also a big fan
of Bruce's decision to incorporate
physical training to his martial arts
and to experiment with entirely new
strategies in that domain too in my
video on Bruce Lee's training I liken
tintin go Keith he wasn't just
interested in performing set routines
and getting incrementally stronger you
wanted to find exciting new ways to push
the limits of human performance Bruce
Lee got his first big break in his
acting career as kaito in the TV series
The Green Hornet following the 1964
exhibition which was seen by television
producer William Dozier he went on to
appear as a guest on several of the TV
shows
Bruce was later advised by producer
thread of winter alb to return to Hong
Kong in order to create a feature film
that he could use as a showcase for us
decision-makers fortunately the Green
Hornet was already successful in Hong
Kong where was actually known as the
Toshio Lee's first movie then was the
big boss in 1971 which is a huge success
across Asia this was then followed by
Fist of Fury in 1972 which the Roku box
office records and way of the Dragon
also in 1972 over which Lee was given
complete creative control immediately
following these successes Bruce went on
to begin filming his intended magnum
opus Game of Death Bruce Lee had become
known not only for his screen presence
and visceral fight scenes but also for
lacing his philosophies into the script
in Game of Death Bruce Lee would fight
using a free and flowing style that
would allow him to adapt to each
opponent and neutralize them even his
weapons nunchakus and a green bamboo
whip would be an expression of this
concept however production was poor so
while he travelled back to the US to
star in Enter the Dragon the film that
eventually made him a superstar in the
u.s. though not before his untimely
death on July 20th 1973 Bruce died
following a cerebral edema swelling of
the brain possibly triggered by or
exacerbated by a common painkiller the
circumstances surrounding his death are
controversial many rumors and theories
speculated that Bruce's death was some
kind of cover-up vendetta or even
deception it's possible that Bruce Lee
was also using cannabis at the time
which he was known to do forensic
pathologist dr. Michael hunter suggests
that Bruce Lee's exceptionally strong
drive and ambition likely played a part
the implication being that he may have
worked himself to death author Matthew
Polly speculates that the edema might
have been triggered by a combination of
overexertion and heatstroke
especially as Bruce Lee had recently had
the sweat glands removed from his
armpits in 1972 for aesthetic purposes
on film while dedication and commitment
to a goal of truly admirable traits it's
also important to always know your limit
what's important to remember here then
is that Bruce Lee was also just a man he
was not perfect and neither are any of
the icons that I'll be discussing in
this series
many were quick to point out Arnie's bad
behavior in my last video but it's only
right that we do the same for Bruce Lee
he himself would not want it any other
way
our job is to take the positive from
these life stories and not to hold
anyone on a pedestal
Bruce's success can be attributed to
many things as we saw with Arnie in the
previous video Bruce was a man who did
not just talk about his goals but would
simply get to work enacting his plans he
did not wait for years before he set up
his martial art school nor did he wait
to be noticed in Hollywood instead he
opted to take matters into his own hands
if you have something you want to
achieve you must not wait and hope and
certainly don't procrastinate or make
excuses the sooner you start working
towards that goal the more contacts
experience and notoriety you'll gain
Bruce was truly a polymath as a
philosopher and author a martial artist
and actor a director and more his
passion for his craft ensured that he
had the energy to pursue every facet of
these interests also like Arnie he knew
how to promote himself creating
elaborate moves that would be memorable
and speaking in quotable soundbites
self-promotion is something that often
taught to shy away from but if you want
to be successful is an invaluable tool
in your arsenal and of course there was
his dedication Bruce augmented natural
skill with self-discipline and endless
hours of practice homing himself into a
force to be reckoned with if you're
skilled enough or if you truly stand out
with unique ideas then you put yourself
out there then it's just a matter of
time until you're seen by the right
people make your own luck
as with many stars who died young and as
with many disruptors who challenge the
status quo Bruce Lee quickly went on to
attain cult status as a global icon he
is revered by many as one of the
greatest martial artists ever to have
lived he is credited with popularizing
martial arts in the west and with
smashing Asian stereotypes in Hollywood
but there are critics who say the
opposite many commenters on my channel
are keen to dismiss Bruce as just an
actor several have stated that Bruce Lee
wouldn't stand a chance against the
modern MMA fighter I've no doubt he
would have been world champion in MMA no
there he's fluid he's loose he's fast
his movement is fluid it's efficient
it's functional so many guys are
addicted to strengthen conditioner he's
get balled up and stiff and slow and
Bruce was free his buddy was nimble
whether the latter statement is true is
up for debate of course there is
absolutely no denying Bruce Lee's talent
or power if you know anything about
martial arts then you only have to
witness one of his kicks dinner he was
supremely skilled and incredibly fast
and powerful footage of Bruce Lee's
sparring with a student has also
recently emerged online wonderfully
restored over at beardies YouTube
channel and while it isn't a flawless
performance it definitely demonstrates
the principles Bruce preached in highly
effective action in an unstated arena
likewise there's no denying that his
physique was one of the most striking of
the time another testament to his will
and dedication there are many rumors
regarding through his strength
Danny and Santo Jai Lewis and Jesse
Glover described Bruce as being able to
hold barbells of 72 125 pounds right out
in front of him with straight arms has
been said that he could puncture a can
of soda with a single finger and those
who experiences one-inch punch say that
it left him winded and injured is any of
this true
I find it suspect that there's no video
evidence of any of these skills
Bruce certainly wasn't shy of filming
himself or of self promoting if he could
jab a finger through a cola can wouldn't
we have seen it and lifting that much
weight with straight arms is incredibly
difficult but then again most of these
feats are possible and have been
accomplished by others the stories are
corroborated by more than one witness
and we know from his training with
overcoming isometrics that he could
generate a lot of power for his small
size and we know from this to finger
push-up that he had a very powerful
fingers so who knows
it's interesting to note though that the
one-inch punch was not really delivered
from an inch but rather from the length
of Bruce's outstretched fingers more
like four to five inches we can't know
for certain how Bruce Lee would perform
against modern fighters because we'll
never have the opportunity to set up
such a match the fact that he inspired
the fighting method with so many of them
used they should count for something
and it certainly disingenuous to
describe him as anything other than a
visionary skilled fighter none of this
is really the point though the point is
that Bruce Lee was magnetic enough and
obviously talented enough that he was
able to smash through prejudices open
closed minds and changed the status quo
were it not for Bruce Lee he likely
wouldn't have Jackie Chan the Karate Kid
martial arts classes all around the
world the matrix or such exposure to
Chinese philosophy it's no surprise that
he was named by Time magazine as one of
the hundred most influential people of
the 20th century and it's only fitting
that we pay homage to him here on the
bio near where our goals and interests
share much in common with the dragon
totally family's really useful
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like and share it around that
helps me out immensely let me know in
the comments down below what you think
about Bruce Lee what inspires you about
his life story and also who'd likely to
cover in future like I say you can head
over to the patreon page if you want to
vote on who's gonna be covered in the
very next learning from legends episode
and in the meantime I have my video on
body language coming up very soon
followed shortly by my video on
Nightwing training and lots of other
cool stuff so if that all sounds cool
then thanks a ton for watching please
subscribe and I'll see you next time bye
for now